it's sort of surprising that they're
announcing earnings after the bell
they're having the call then that's not
what we normally hear from them and bill
said to me a month ago
even that is suspect they know there's
bad news coming yeah it's certainly a
shift for Herbalife I mean if it were
like a Friday and a three-day week and I
think that might even have more credence
but it is a change for this company the
way that they present information and
they're constantly changing the way they
present information but I think it's
useful to look at what's going out of
this company and separate it from the
sort of you know he said he said battle
it you know Ackman versus I don't know
it's the Wall Street battle to me isn't
as interesting is what's happening this
underlying business and what's happened
in the business it's it's slowing down
dramatically and you could see it last
quarter when it really took hold
we could see signs of it before but when
you saw the sales growth and the sales
themselves revenue for this company
really start to you know it could
continue to grow put in a much slower
pace a much much slower pace and while
the sales slowed down quite a bit the
profit slowed down significantly their
operating profits just absolutely
collapsed with just that down tick and
sales growth Corian so when you look at
yeah could it be that they're in the
middle of the perfect storm let's say
Bill Ackman is right and they have been
up to no good maybe under their new
management and they have changed a lot
of their distributor guidelines now
maybe they're finally flying straight
flying right and they're trying to do it
at a time when the strong dollar is
killing them so they can't get out of
this vortex well so two things there so
the company is certainly paying
attention to Bill Ackman and it has
changed the way that they do certain
business practices responding to his
criticism the way that leads are sold
within the business the top earners are
no longer able to have side businesses
selling leaves that changes the way they
do business so they haven't said we
don't care what you're saying bill a can
we're to keep doing what we've always
done and do it right they've changed
their business in response to his
criticism now what's important here when
the currency side though is yes the
currency is is another perfect storm
hitting them the Venezuelan currency
just the change in that one currency and
their evaluation of that slapped their
earnings last quarter but look what's
happened globally since then we've had
an absolute
collapse in the price in the Euro or
just which is one of their biggest
markets we've actually add the Chinese
currencies actually improved a little
bit since they last gave guidance but
across the board you've seen global
currencies collapse their cost of goods
are in US dollars the revenues are
increasingly overseas and their growth
is overseas so when those dollars coming
in from overseas or those pesos or the
zeros or the China RMB coming when those
are at a lower value than the last time
they gave guidance that could be a big
surprise after the belt today I will be
shocked what do you honestly gonna hide
what do you honestly think is gonna
happen here Cory I mean it's not
actually a battle of the Wall Street
wills anymore because so many guys were
on the other side of this trade are out
yeah look a fundamentally the company's
gonna have to stand on his own and and
these issues you know the places where
they're growing it's the the business
that it is can only grow so much they
can only have so many locations they can
only have so many diet clubs in a single
block and they've started to push the
limits of that that's why the growth
overseas is so important because the
limits in the u.s. may have been reached
that's why their biggest growth has been
in those other places like Mexico like
China like you know China's one of their
biggest markets so the they start to
push against a limit somewhere when they
change as business practises look we're
starting to see those results I think
that's why last quarter was so important
I think that's why this Court is gonna
be so fundamentally important forget the
FTC examinations forget whether this is
about an illegal multi-level marketing
scheme or not just the business itself
seems to be suffering under its own way
Cory I just want to share for a minute a
clip of the conversation I had just a
couple weeks ago with Bill I know he
keeps saying to us wait for it wait for
a big news coming but he named February
26 sort of is d-day take a look
interestingly they're holding a
conference call after the close as
opposed to 10:00 in the morning the
following day I think it's a little bit
of a tell that the numbers are gonna be
bad so Cory you know many people have
said listen bill you've told us in the
past this is going to be the biggest
presentation the biggest aha moment but
if you look quietly this trade has
started to go Bills direction at
year-and-a-half ago I mean he was
underwater with some of the biggest
hedge fund Giants standing on his front
yard with bazookas that's not really the
case anymore well he
strategy also to be so concentrated in
so few names it's very hot in the hedge
fund industry right now is those super
concentrated philosophies they're a lot
of fun to fund managers that are pushing
money into those for those funds that
are so concentrated in those positions
and it's all in but you know imagine
what goes on the other side right when
you're a hedge fund analyst and you've
got a huge position and that company is
reporting you loved to have the night to
go over the numbers and to read
everything that was possible you hate
the conference call right when the
numbers hit before the filing happens
that's the way most companies do at
herbalife doing that as well but it
doesn't give you the chance to do the
analysis to be ready to ask the smartest
questions when the conference call comes
around